[Musik]
das heeresgeschichtlichen museum war
heute am 20 november 2008 10
schauplatz einer feierlichen übernahme
eines sehr seltenen fahrzeuges der
kampfpanzer m4a 1 schirmen gewisse
dieses exemplar ist einer von nur 100 88
stück denn kanada 1943 hergestellten
variante des schirmen
er war bei den kanadischen streitkräften
in italien im einsatz
in anwesenheit von generalsekretär
magister doktor wolfgang baumann
übereinander direktor des
heeresgeschichtlichen museums dr
mario christian ortner die leihgabe aus
großbritannien
der panzer befindet sich übrigens im
besitz des techno see und momentan in
südwestengland der größten und ältesten
panzer sammlung der welt
chris lee ist ein teil der firmen story
und diese german story diese geschichte
zeigt dass der kampf band 4 in all
seinen varianten eigentlich ein
meilenstein der militärtechnik ist
japans avant nie der beste
er war auch nie das schnellste waren
wieder feuer kräftigste aber er war ein
panzer der in massenproduktion gefertigt
wurde und dafür ausgelegt wurde
das heißt man hat diesen panzer auf die
bedürfnisse der fließbandproduktion in
den usa abgestimmt und daher konnte
beispielsweise einen in den märkten bei
ford in den usa
im halbstundentakt
kampfpanzer vom fließband gelassen
werden in wien wird der kampfpanzer ab
dritten märz 2009 10 für besucher des
heeresgeschichtlichen museums zu sehen
sein